good afternoon as mr. Bell said I am my
name is ty Etta Mindy I'm a junior econ
major here at Hillsdale and I'm also a
captain the track and field team and it
is my honor to introduce our speaker
today Michael Novak is a distinguished
visiting professor at Ave Maria
University in Florida a graduate of the
Georgian University in Rome and Harvard
University mr. Novak held the chair in
religion and public policy at the
American Enterprise Institute in
Washington DC for 32 years he is a
recipient of the Templeton Prize and was
on three occasions US ambassador under
President Ronald Reagan for this and
other service including his work on the
boards of Radio Free Europe and Radio
Liberty he was given the highest awards
bestowed on foreign citizens by the
Czech Republic Poland and Slovakia mr.
Novak is the author of numerous books
including the universal hunger for
liberty the joy of sports the spirit of
democratic capitalism which was
translated and published in the Polish
underground in 1984 and most recently
writing from left to right my journey
from liberal to conservative please join
me in welcoming mr. Michael Novak
I was happy to hear Matt say that he was
a Mets fan I just want to tell him
Dodger can I just say if he alert Dodger
fan because every one of my phone
numbers has 42 in it what for
Jackie Robinson's cyan play several
times in Forbes Field in Pittsburgh my
talk is called why we love sports it's
not long if any of you have read george
will's book on baseball men at work in
1990 which came out some years after my
own book The Joy of sports in 1976 you
will have noticed a distinct difference
between a Protestant and the Catholic
approach to sports both traditions
illuminate both are useful each in its
own way and in fact they complement each
other now there are several evidences
that will was not only quite aware of
the difference but it took some pains to
call attention to it part of the
difference can be seen in our very two
different book titles will stressed work
men at work while I stress joy I first
noticed this sort of difference in
political ads during the 1960
presidential campaigns of John Kennedy
and Richard Nixon the 1960 election was
the first to hold a televised debate
between the nominees of the two parties
public expectations ran very high for
some days political ads for the Nixon
campaign during that period highlighted
the work habits of Nixon in his
preparation Nixon writing industriously
on the legal pad under the lamp late at
night burning the midnight oil Nixon the
hard worker the serious man
by contrast the Kennedy campaign
released an ad which showed the Kennedy
family playing touch football on the
beach Nixon at work Kennedy at play
oddly playing on the beach before so
crucial a televised debate suggested
needed the competences already mastered
no sweat during the actual debate Nixon
showed a nervous sweat Kennedy seemed
more jaunty and fast on his feet
analogously wil was eager to show the
amount of hard work sweat and attention
to detail that the highly existed in the
Cal Ripken poured into baseball now
George and I used to go to the games in
Baltimore to see them saw Cal Ripken
play brave George a lot more regularly
than I did the iron man started every
game for 2632 straight nobody has even
come close
cows was an inspiring story and I loved
what he achieved still what I would like
to stress is a joy and total
concentration the cow put into his play
as if he were working outside of time
and space in a light of eternity
Aristotle and the Greek and Christian
traditions of contemplation taught me to
think of play as an end in itself
hard competition may teach many virtues
form human character and imbue a spirit
of discipline and even asceticism no
pain no gain but what I remember best
about playing football basketball and
baseball is a young boy at the Holy
Trinity Base football as well basically
where the moments in which I
concentrated so hard on the situation at
the moment they lost all track of time I
felt as if I were living in another
domain altogether when I heard my
mother's voice shouting from our back
porch that dinner was ready I often
couldn't believe her it seemed as if no
time had passed at all which is started
to me as a boy concentrating hard in an
intense game was like living in a turn
'ti outside of time and it filled me
with a special kind of joy that even now
lifts my spirits from all this I later
learned to grasp what Aristotle meant in
his distinction between the world of
ends and the world of means after this I
came upon the work of Aquinas on
contemplation for the Latin words con +
templum or temple being gathered in a
temple and there's part of the religious
origins of sports in the old Olympics
intended by that
contemplation such as one experiences in
an hour or so silent prayer in the
presence of God or in the awe and
subdued but joyous silence one feels
before a sublimely beautiful work of art
in this respect I especially remember
seeing for the first time and many times
since in Florence book two cellies The
Birth of Venus and later the vincey's
lady with an ermine before both of these
I've sat for many silent half hours just
taking it in contemplation is an intense
concentration intense may be the wrong
word because it's it's relaxed and it's
just absorbing it's let it all coming
into you enjoy every detail of it and
let your I follow the detail
contemplation is an intense
concentration such that one feels
outside oneself these experiences are
quite akin to what I have felt at high
moments of play and I'm going to quote
from time to time from the joy of sports
and this is one quote to be at the right
place at the right time all the truisms
leap to mind to keep cool to handle
hundreds of details and call exactly the
plays that work to fight ones way
through opposition and to do what one
wills to do against odds against
probabilities these are to practice a
very high art to achieve a few moments
of beauty that will for a lifetime the
lights of memory of those who watched or
listened or read what we mean by legend
is what we mean by art the reaching of a
form a perfection which ordinarily flesh
mass
a form eternal in its beauty it is as
though muscle and nerves and spirit and
comrades were working together as
flawlessly as God once imagined human
beings might in a certain sense I know
one plays in order to work out get some
exercise keep in shape all instrumental
purposes aiming and some extrinsic go
not the joy of the play but to play is
also to treat an activity as a joy in
itself I so love the crack of a bat that
magical sound every spring we're about
to hear it soon the swish of a net and
the wind ringing in my ears
as I outrun the last defender reaching
out and getting my fingertips on the
ball hauling it into my chest and
sprinting ahead there's nothing like
that nothing like that it's just perfect
and you practice for so long to get the
timing down and everything else but the
joy of achieving it under pressure in
the game is unbelievably intense and
joyous the Greeks used to refer to such
an experience as living in the time of
the heroes that is performing something
so perfect so excellent that it carried
one outside the humdrum of everyday the
endless practices the learning of the
required disciplines you know it doesn't
matter how many times you practice a
play or a pass or the only one that
counts is when the clock is ticking
and to hit it then and right in stride
and right as it was meant to be is again
so hi pleasure the taste of excellence
in act is Aristotle's very definition of
happiness happiness is not a feeling oh
for goodness sake
I can't believe I didn't
I'm so sorry
so in it allas allas definition of
happiness is to perform perfect
perfectly to perform at the top of your
game and there is no happiness like that
but it's not a feeling it's an
achievement do you see the difference
the moderns take a different tack and I
think - their loss anyway in the rest of
my education Joseph pieper of the German
scholars measure the basis of culture
yarn hosing of Dutch homo Luden's man
the player Loulou dances play
Hugo Rahner man at play and James shawls
two books easily pleased a theology of
play contemplation and festivity and his
other book play on from games to
celebrations both of all those best
illuminate moments I have experienced in
sport these books rang true give me the
right the joy of sports back in about
1974 or 5 I don't remember I know it
came out in 76
now what person I was coming back from
work on the Long Island subway long on a
train from Manhattan hour-and-a-half
voyage each way
how can one do that but anyway they were
well how we did it is they served little
plastic glasses of scotch
at the back of the Train and I was
swirling the Scotch in my cup and I
remembered Monday night Monday Night
Baseball and the Dodgers are on and
they're playing since in that series of
the season that but one game behind and
now my wife is not a believer I mean she
just didn't get sports you know I prayed
for her I fasted I I didn't I did
everything I could but she just didn't
see and so I found myself going up to
bed on my own birthday and watching the
Dodgers and it was a good game and they
were in it and then they lost at the end
now I was 40 years old and I was
depressed I was really now I didn't even
know who the Dodgers were by this point
when I grew up they were in Brooklyn and
I lived in Pennsylvania we had a farm
club for the Dodgers so I loved them
ever since I was a little boy I didn't
know what Dodgers meant I didn't know
how they got the name but and I love
them everyone and so I'm depressed I
said Michael you're 40 years old you're
not a kid you didn't even know the names
of these players how can you possibly be
depressed but the thought kept nagging
me but the truth is I am when the
Dodgers lose something's not right with
the world and when the Dodgers win it's
heaven that's the way it should be
and
well
Notre Dame had a coach a few years back
they started out the seasons
saying he was teaching the guys that
it's just a game already I knew he was a
loser it is not a game it is it's too
important for a game and I saw the year
I make him a good friend of Jack Kemp
and he used to invite me because of his
Super Bowl rings to the Super Bowl every
year as long as I gave a talk on sports
to his fundraisers so I did and I
remember one of the first of those games
it was the Dallas Cowboys and I'm pretty
sure the Pittsburgh Steelers I'm not
positive but I know it was Dallas and
they had a habit of losing and the Super
Bowl they'd clean up the league and the
playoffs and then that lose in the final
game I think three times it happened and
this time they were winning and then
Pittsburgh scored twice and you could
see in on the you know really at the
last minute and you can see the joyous
expectation of the Cowboys on the bench
when they were winning rooting and
cheering and up on the sidelines and
when Pittsburgh scored their faces just
fell and it was like they were tasting
ash and it was like they died and that's
true that's what happens this is my
experience I cannot stand to lose I mean
I do my best to be a good loser but I
don't like it and the whole thing is the
whole thing is whatever the odds to play
so well or so cleverly do you somehow
pull it out and when you don't do that
the gods are not spying on you the wind
is not at your back and it's not a nice
feeling and there are other days when
you can't do anything wrong and it's not
exactly your fault it you just
hot I remember once I was shooting
baskets on the court and there's a
little kid watching a ten year old at
the side and I must have shot 17 or 18
from just outside the foul line swish
swish swish
I said mister could you teach me to do
that
I said sure kid and I started saying you
know first you do this I like to dribble
first and then jump up a little bit like
this nothing would go in
I kept bouncing off and I said kid will
you go back there and sit down I mean
you have it or you don't have it and you
don't exactly control it it's one reason
why military people and athletes and
it's true also business people are the
most religious of the 50 top elites in
the country they all experience often
that things are not entirely in their
control everything has to break the
right way and if it doesn't it's really
hard to put it together and when
everything drops it's just a wonderful
wonderful feeling well anyway now
another writer helped me to grasp the
further point vivid experiences in
sports illuminate basic concepts of the
liberal arts such as a Gwang and
awareness of unity of purpose in a
combat or athletic contest and few few
men in my youth and now a good thing
women can also experience it but that
came in my lifetime the contest the
struggle the agony of trying to win and
absolutely crucial importance of every
person on your team doing the same thing
the crucial purpose of importance of
teamwork and picking up for one another
you know your buddy at guard as a bum
knee and you know you got to pick up for
it and nobody gives you orders you just
do it
and that adaptation of the game
second-by-second to how somebody else
needs help it's one eye another of the
great joys of life well anyway there was
an immigrant scholar from Switzerland
who was came to the United States during
World War two
out of flight from the Nazis his name
was awakened Rosenstock you see he tried
for some years to find concrete examples
to teach of the liberal arts and they
tried to find concrete examples of life
in the among American undergraduates
four main points about the liberal arts
that he didn't have to struggle to
explain in Europe because people saw
them in statues and monuments and heard
stories all their life about them
but he did notice that something similar
was available to young Americans in
sports and so he tried out a hypothesis
which he tried out over many years he
began to work with his students
familiarity when the rugged sports on
would stay engaged on campus crew
baseball football rugby track and field
basketball he called the attention of
students to the Eroica acts they strove
for every day in sports trying to make
an impossible play an impossible catch a
desperately needed hit whatever under
pressure and trying to do it just
exactly well you try and sometimes it
works sometimes the gods bless you so he
just called attention to them and I've
taught a class in sports as a liberal
art and I love the part where I start
asking students tell me your most vivid
memory in sports what's the point of
peak joy in sports they all have them
the guys the girls and their lovely
little stories but they remember them
for they will never forget them they
have a peak experiences of life so
closing the stuff goosey pointed out
these heroic acts every day or got the
students to point them out their
favorite moment in sports failure or
success by the way one of the great
things about sports is how many times
you fail I mean the best baseball team
of all time lost one-third of its games
in this season and for years I thought
that's what great advantage males had
over females
did you enjoy public failure so often
and boy did guys rag you about it guys
have tough on each other
I I can remember a friend of mine
hitting a home run and when he comes
back to the bench his best friend says
you gotta lay off those high fastballs
that's the way guys are and I really
like it now when my daughter's played
their field hockey or whatever else they
played they were so supportive of one
another
I had to choke back my rage this is not
for fun kids anyway yeah so then he
would use in class he would pick out
concepts from Homer from Aristotle from
the other ancients to open up these
experiences these sports experiences to
deeper understanding virtually virtues
commonly celebrated in the liberal arts
in in Homer in the Iliad in the Odyssey
such as the ability to endure pain
persistence in defeat the use of quick
wit in gaining advantage over foes the
commitment of every member of the team
to one another and their sheer
determination to prevail they're just
not gonna lose all these have been
frequently been experienced by athletes
American sports and the liberal arts
would make a truly illuminating
University course and I've done it I did
it mostly to spite the professors who
looked out on the athletes and there
anyway
many passages of Homer and Virgil evoke
experiences already familiar to young
American athletes in their sports this
is how Joe Paterno a professor of
classics taught football as what his
players most cited later is what they
learned about life it´ll came right out
of the Greeks and the Romans and I'm
grateful that all his victories have
been restored to him and in fact the
NCAA which was so cruel to him and
unjust and unfair finally published its
rules on the ideal way of handling cases
like he ran into and they stated exactly
what Joe did and it's just it's just one
of those wonderful turns of justice but
alas takes so long he lost his life in
the misery of it anyway the modern mind
tends to be organized around the two
realities of power knowledge is power
and work don't just stand there do
something
both restlessly pursued in a good name
of progress this focus of mind is the
lens through which many journalists and
social scientists nowadays perceive
sports compared with their serious
colleagues on the news science and
business pages many sports journalists
seem vaguely ashamed of reporting on kid
stuff what are sports doing to change
the world when such journalists look at
sports nowadays they are visibly
preoccupied with its financial side its
successes its psychology social
significance and personal scandals for
instance in the 8th edition of D Stanley
i'ts in sports in contemporary society
parts two three four
two three and four focus on
socialization among youth in the mass
media and in the widespread use of
Native American names and mascots parts
five to nine address problems of excess
such as overzealous parents like me
sexual assaults drugs in big-time
college sports parts 10 to 12 addressed
structured inequality in relation to
race and ethnicity gender and sexuality
and the final part 13 includes three
articles on globalization when the whole
bloody book is problems shortcomings
excesses not a word of the games it's
themselves the highly concentrated
highly prepared play the preparation the
game plan the narrative the narrative
above all have you ever missed the game
on television or something and you go to
look it up in the newspapers the next
day you have the darnest I'm buying an
account of the story what was a great
breakthrough plays they drop that
nowadays they drop the heroic stuff and
they give you a sociology I don't have
anything in sociology but not what I
want to know about the game in actual
practice though there is joy for the
players there's joy for the spectators
but that joy is experienced only through
the actual working out of the narrative
of the game its moments of suspense its
heroic acts its turning points it's
unforgettable plays in older days
accounts of sports even in daily
newspapers used to dwell on these
dramatic questions the sports pages were
really fun they were works of art some
of the language could be chiseled in
marble right I in the sport book joy of
sports I I quote the entire text
against Callie's ninth-inning bright of
the ninth-inning perfect game of Sandy
Koufax it's only about this high on the
page there is not one wasted word not an
extra breath just the essence of what
sandy did understate it it is just
brilliant just a perfect piece of art
and it used to be like that
the game came alive to you the narrative
I miss it all of Isis topics are worthy
subjects and they're well researched and
well argued they teach us much that is
interesting so they are far afield from
the central issue they could as well be
found in other sections of a newspaper
such as business society there were the
television pages they do little to probe
into sports for what they are
if sports games played and presented
just for the joy of it and the work of
it and the sweat of it and the suffering
of it and how you overcame obstacles in
it in actual practice there is joy for
the players there's joy for the
spectators well I've said that so worse
one often hears sports broadcasters this
I hate most speak of their games as
entertainment in fact sports games are
much more than entertainment a business
traveler will find that most nights of
the week patrons around the bar at his
hotel or motel don't pay much attention
to the television set fills as it is
with entertainment but when Monday Night
Football was on the set a newcomer does
well to stand in respectful silence
until a break in the action since most
of the spectators are absorbed by the
drama in the arena and resists being
interrupted they are in a frame of mind
more inward and contemplative then
extroverted in this world just looking
for distraction and a college football
game while the game is in play intense
fans
as little as possible game time is a
little bit like the high holy moment
when respectful silence and
concentration are in order entertainment
is what happens at halftime when the
bands come marching out and the singers
perform and most of the fans run to the
bathroom or purchase more hot dogs uh
beers it's entertainment not the game
the game itself is not entertainment its
power goes far beyond diversion
sometimes the game so absorbs us that at
the end we feel exhausted as if we have
played ourselves I remember on the night
we are engaged I was such a happy fellow
I said we got to celebrate so I called
the Boston arena and because the last
appearance of the Lakers in Boston but
the Celtics was on and it was tie again
and Bob Cousy was playing so this would
be Bob kisses last night in Boston for
the playoff berth player and I called
the guy laughed at me he wanted a ticket
see then he said well he said we do have
one behind the pillar and he said you
can see one side of the court but you
can't see the other I said I'll take it
and we went but Karen almost ended her
engagement right there because I got so
intense in the game and was you know up
on my feet sweaty and worried about
every play every call and she's an
artist what she fell in love with was
Bob Cousy skill and his art and his
talent he would fake guys right out of
their socks I mean he'd start one way
and they'd be looking at the board sheet
over that way an easy basket and it was
just beautiful to watch anyway
so coming out of a really great game
football game let's say it's like coming
out of another and better world
especially if you win
now suddenly returned to the profane
prosaic unbeautiful world of finding
one's own on a mobile what a jar
what a comedown on the other hand of its
Philadelphia and the Redskins and the
Redskins win it's an unpleasant
experience exiting the stadium
philadelphia doesn't like to lose they
lose ugly and you better stay out of the
way but anyway okay so it's not just
entertainment it really isn't okay is in
the moments when we are caught up in
playing or in participant viewing which
is very different from spectating that
we come closest to experience to
experiencing human existence outside of
time at a sports event quoting again
there may be spectators just as some
people come to church to hear the music
but a participant is not a spectator
merely even if he does not walk among
the clergy at a liturgy elected
representatives perform the formal acts
but all believers put their hearts into
the ritual it is considered inadequate
almost blasphemous to be a mere
spectator fans are not mere spectators
if they wanted no more than to pass the
time to find diversion there are cheaper
and less internally exhausting ways to
get there sports are rituals concerning
human survival on this planet it's life
and death on the field if you take the
game on its own terms and when you lose
you feel like you died and when you win
if you just can't do anything wrong for
ten is in your sails why are all the
sports teams made in and
ovals to celebrate the goddess Fortuna
football was designed around the breaks
I mean the ball was deliberately made
not round the bounce and angles that you
can't control it's built around fortune
and I have a friend who was worried
about all the wear and tear on pro
basketball players and 120 games or
however many they play and he suggested
that what they ought to do is only play
one minute and sell it right there say
hello and ear which is usually the best
part of the game anyway
and ok it is shock some of it in my
earlier writings I speak of certain
sports events as liturgies the
dictionary definition of liturgy is a
right or body of Rights prescribed for
public worship right is defined right
RIT II is defined as a set form for
conducting a ceremony and a ceremonial
act or action just so a participant
knows exactly what forms to expect as a
football baseball or basketball ceremony
is about to get underway and in the
United States at least the ceremonies
are great sports liturgies are very
often consecrated by a prayer to the
divine or we're not by acts of piety and
reverence toward the nation and the
history the much blessed history of a
reservation observing these with some
amazement G K Chesterton the British
writer once described America as a
nation with the soul of a church and
even when he observed an inauguration of
a president it opened was a prayer and
closed with the refrain accepted in one
one occasion one election closer to the
frame god Bless America and he said he
couldn't do that
couldn't do it in France but in America
politics sports it always begins with
the almighty nation with the soul of a
church now our three sports the Holy
Trinity are each based around a
different mythical structure different
narrative structure I'm not gonna linger
on this but just let me mention football
essentially is a narrative of the will
to run for daylight through eleven
hulking monsters intent on destructing
that will it's a narrative of overcoming
obstacles by sheer spunk and wit
baseball by contest is a Lockean
narrative of liberty and law the voice
of the umpire rules on every play the
law strike ball in out
and it's not only law and liberty it's a
very freewheeling game but it's also
ordered symmetrical calming and it's
designed to test whether those who run
will be brought home it's like the
Yankee Clipper ships going out around
the world the point of the game is to
come home and that's what it isn't
baseball it's where the runs are
basketball is a narrative of human
shiftiness faint deception and
laser-like passing designed to penetrate
at all active and intensely alert
defensive five it's hard to imagine how
much poor the United States would be
culturally poor morally pure poorer
aesthetically poor and contemporary poor
if it holding that these three great
ceremonial actions these teachers both
of personal courage and communal
intensity because it's the whole team
and it's the whole crowd experience it
get together that's again half the fun
that's a huge dimension to the play for
human beings the most important thing is
the realm of ends and of being and
beauty and truth this steps we come
closest to in play it is so in the
interior life in prayer it is also so in
the experience of the great highlights
and intuitions of eternity the heroic
and the more than human that even young
boys and girls begin first to know in
sports I know of nothing that has taught
my took my son and two daughters and
their children so much about the depths
of life then there are experiences of
courage teamwork defeat vector E and
in the sports they loved in school it's
different to go in a matter of weeks six
weeks from being the littlest kid on the
team who's inexcusable miss play
I hurried home from work one day to get
to see my son play literally he was
about seven and he was always the tenth
man chosen so he's out in right field
and they were winning last out guy hits
a flyball out toward right field my son
is very excited makes one mistake he
runs in and the ball runs out now I'm
crossing the field thinking how am I
gonna console him what guys I said you
know you have degrees in both philosophy
and theology you should have something
to say when I got there and I started to
say something I have no idea what but I
got there my son said dad don't say a
word
I lost a game that's it and so he went
he was really dejected lost for the
whole team for the whole season
and then in basketball season he comes
up with the final shot and wins the game
in in overtime now what could I do or
how could I teach him to live through
those two experiences and Lord or just
of weeks failure in which he knew he
blew it he was responsible no excuses
and then you know as small as he was on
the team taking the final shot and
dropping it how could you teach what
could I do to teach his son something
like that and the growth that occurred
between those things and the way he
knows that a lot of his Fortuna and a
lot of it is you made the wrong play you
were in the wrong way and the other one
you shot and
luckily we're hot you got it you know
you miss a lot of them in practice okay
so sports do not teach us every lesson
in about life for guys they don't teach
us much about women and that turns out
to be an important part of life but what
they do need us to is invaluable every
profession can after time grow stale so
let me conclude on a cautionary note
quoting again sports are not of course
all of life what could our courage
honesty freedom community and excellence
if they do not inform one's family
family life civic life political life
and work life sports are not everything
but they do not celebrate such qualities
in order to contain them but in order to
hold them clearly before the aspiring
heart no one can live a life wholly
within sports for professional athletes
sports themselves may become work not
sports justice for the professional
academic studies may become work not
liberal arts just as for a professional
clergyman religion may become work not
spirit
so I conclude on this note play on live
intensely taste eternity work work work
but in the end in order to exalt you
work in order to play you don't play in
order to work
to paraphrase st. Irenaeus in the second
century the glory of God
is the athlete fully alive thanks very
much
we now time for a few questions please
stand when the microphone comes to you
what do you mean a few questions my
record time period for a question period
is nine hours this the political season
now and a big issue is inequality
Bharani makes a big issue out of their
businessmen that make greedy businessmen
making millions of dollars but it seems
that sports people making millions of
dollars aren't excluded from this an
explanation
these men are evil when they make
millions sports men are heroes when you
make millions and they are I agree well
I think if the achievement of the thing
it takes so much work and so much
practice and so much discipline and so
much love of one fellows remember
student women athletes it I've been
really worried teaching they talked
about what it was like to be on their
basketball team and now that never
before experienced such an intensity
depending on one another and then break
their knees for whatever their whatever
it took it's it's such a beautiful human
event glory when you play at the top of
your form that you remember it for all
time and people who see it remembered I
mean I'm sure you've seen baseball plays
that you've never forgotten you might
have been 11 years old and now John
Fritos catch against the right-field
wall and so on that's just living glory
well you see you have me here because I
do think it the same is true in business
and I don't understand I used to be a
left of left and one thing that made me
more conservative about it is I couldn't
understand housing people of the
political party I didn't belong to kept
talking about jobs jobs jobs but they
hated employers now that just doesn't
work I mean you can't have employees
without employers so one of the greatest
acts of social justice in the world I
think it's the one we need most in the
world in which we live our people can
create small businesses Latin America
needs about 20 million of them employing
between 10 and 15 persons age or even
fewer but you get the idea and Africa
more there's enormous unemployment and
underemployment and both those
continents but what doesn't make sense
is an awful lot to do on those
continents it's tremendous number of
things to be done in there a tremendous
number of men and women who are not
doing them well how does that happen
what happens is the entrepreneur who
comes with a spark to inspire and direct
people to create and do the jobs that
need to be done and in there and along
with that create an income now you can
tell in the United States the inequality
figures there is an equality of income
but gosh look at the figures for the
people who work and don't work the
number of people who don't work at all
is in the millions well there's no way
they're gonna have
equal income especially since when they
get handouts in the government it
doesn't count
the government doesn't count those and
it's poverty figures so I'm with James
Madison and with Leo the 13th Pope Leo
the 13th both of whom said in their
slightly different ways the pursuit of
equality is a wicked project it's
inhuman look at your own family if you
have five six or relevent Maria we
usually have seven or eight kids they're
all different and even if they're highly
talented they're differently motivated
and you can't you couldn't enforce one
regime on all the kids you just couldn't
do it if you tried so the other 13th has
a passage in which he says that the
pursuit of equality is futile
it's mistaken wrong in its conception
and it's evil and a good society needs
lots of variety of people not everybody
can do the same jobs and it would drive
me crazy they'd have to be in Tollbooth
collecting tickets all day but there are
people were glad for the job that's
controlled ours and there it takes all
kinds of people as the point so why
would you want to make everybody equal
it doesn't make any sense it can't be
done anyway so there's a there's a
mythical pursuit of equality in the
modern world which is the root of
socialism and communism and state
statism
and it doesn't make any sense and
anybody using common sense can see it
doesn't make any sense anyway I'm sorry
I didn't mean to go off on that yeah I
did
mrs. mr. Novik most of the younger
people here obviously are part of the
call it the Sports Center generation
where you're watching highlights and
seeing things on TV and a 24/7 news
cycle would you encourage them to go
back and read some of the great sports
writers like Redd Smith and Jim Murray
and Dave Anderson maybe Bob Ryan from
the Boston Globe
people like that excuse me Grantland
rice
Grantland rice of course yeah just just
to get a flavor that good writing is
good writing regardless of the subject
it's it's gone for most sports reporting
because they've lost the story they've
lost the narrative and it's the
narrative the mythic struggle that has
all the hidden power of it and it's
tragic that that happened it doesn't
need to happen kids like the games
anyway they see it they know the reality
by the way the guy who invented
basketball the third part of the Trinity
was a Protestant minister and his dot
job was preparing missionaries so
crucial to them was building up the
health and stamina this is pretty early
on and and but what could you do is in
Massachusetts what could you do in
December or January coming up here from
Florida I ask myself but so he decided
they needed to play sports so he used
the gym but he discovered the guys don't
really like to just do exercises and
calisthenics and so forth so he decided
to invent the game that they could play
indoors then to fill their minds and
hearts and he was Protestant so it had
to be a goal oriented so his first
question was where is he gonna put the
goals and the question was is he put
them on this on you know on the wall and
he's got another heart each other too
much throwing the ball of
so he put them up 10 feet high and you
had to throw to score you had to throw a
gentle mark of grace yeah and in the
game
I moved I'm teasing of course but
there's there's some truth in it so yeah
but it's a different mythos from
football or baseball if you set it to
music would be a whole different kind of
music you know for football you need a
pretty big Symphony or concert for
baseball you can do it with them what do
they cost the word I want for it you
know a quartet or quintet you know just
a piano this nice going with the green
grass and then well you know they say
Americans are activists who are always
too busy
they haven't watched baseball I mean you
know nothing happens for
fifteen minutes at a time but it's very
American that's rural America that's
where it grew up and my wife is in Iowa
and I said love to sit on the back porch
in the mornings and this is it the grass
grow it would be cutter in the morning
and by noon it's being in child ready
you know anyway he almost crackled it
grew so much but basketball has to be
jazz you know everybody plays to a
different melody and you just get to
come together every Sullivan every
instrument is improvising every player
is improvising it's it's just a a very
different sport and it's living on a
different mythos is teaching a different
ethic and these three the reason I like
to pay attention to but all three were
invented by Americans it was said I
think by Tocqueville even that in
America there are no games Americans
don't play games
well that was before the 1860s and after
Doubleday and then football Carlisle
Pennsylvania and then as I said
basketballs 30 or 40 years later these
are those games invented by Americans
for Americans nobody played them for
years by the way I learned an
interesting thing from the Koreans I was
giving lectures on economics and
democracy and one instead I've been said
look we noticed we hate the Japanese so
we're always competing with them
and he said we noticed it the Japanese
didn't take off development didn't occur
until they brought in baseball and he
said the reason why is in Japan as in
China there was no place for the
individual you did things in great
groups massive amounts of people would
clear an air pear base and so on and in
baseball you had to go to the plate one
at a time nobody could go there for you
and that plant was choked can you do it
and then on the other hand the game of
teamwork you know a team is only as good
as its ninth member and and also you
learn it by law everything in baseball
happens by law so you learn Liberty and
law individual and team and he gets
third one I can't remember
he said we started to play baseball
that's what we took off I think there's
a lot of merit in that argument you need
to say the set of habits in order to
bring about development in democracy and
in capital by capitalism I mean the
economy based on invention and discovery
they don't look around this room this
fantastic ball of water this microphone
the cloth the chairs you're sitting in
the rugs none of these existed at the
time of the founders
they've all been invented in the last
200 and some years and what made that
possible Lincoln pointed out is the
patent Copyright Act which he said it as
the 6th greatest step in the history of
Liberty for the first time it changed
the meaning of wealth which used to mean
land the great
full of inequality and made the main
source of ideas source of wealth ideas
and the poorest guy could have the
invention that made him fabulously
wealthy it changed the whole drama of
economic life from a land owning society
to an inventive society and anyway sorry
I didn't mean to go off that way but we
have time for one more question you
touched on how sport leads us to beauty
and truth and then you mentioned how
sports can shape our lives with failure
and success and the growth in between
and with our education system for like
elementary school middle schools falling
many parts the United States obesity on
the rise and young children it seems
like sports would play an important part
in a child's development yet more and
more schools are cutting out recess time
in sports in exchange for other programs
would you say that sports should be a
required part of a child's education
well I don't want to condemn it to death
but but there's something very silly
going on in our society parents is so
afraid of their children getting hurt
there's almost no free time gosh my
parents used to let us go on hiking in
the hills and so forth and whatever
adventures we came up one they wouldn't
all be pretty would be better for it
no supervised play and to play baseball
we know how to pick up teams and we know
how to set up bases and with a rock or
something
pillow work not a pillow but a pad or
something and we would just do it and it
was really rough and we didn't know the
rules for soccer that wasn't
the American games and we just caught it
soft him and you know we weren't quite
as tough as the Canadians I mean my
buddies in Canada they described the the
what do you call it the thing over the
fireplace the mantel that's the word I
want I'm 82 years old I have the same
photographic memory I had at 25 but I
don't have any film and I I just can't
get it I know it's there but I can't get
okay so mantel with little jars of
formaldehyde with every one of the
stitches they've had and the guy with
the most stitches is the most proud and
mom's probably you know and okay so but
look isn't it true there on campus the
place that doesn't get or need
affirmative action sports with merit and
pure merit what you know maybe not pure
but merit more than any other place in
the campus and senator Hayakawa a
Japanese senator from Hawaii said it
wasn't fair he said there should be an
affirmative action unit for Japanese and
pro basketball but anyway you know it's
just it's just not that way and we're
quality counts and excellence counts and
perfection counts and our cherished
that's a great gift of ethics to
American life and okay
thank you very much
thanks a lot
you